[Musique]
nous sommes le jeudi 5 janvier 2017 et
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 les 1/8 et les missions qui vous
permet de découvrir celles et ceux qui
font l'actualité dans le département et
vous entendrez aujourd'hui à dominique
mocka entrepreneurs mais aussi inventeur
son créneau l'automobile il a transformé
et des voitures à essence en voiture
électrique il a aussi rendu impossible
le pilotage de sa voiture avec un
smartphone il nous présentera
aujourd'hui une nouvelle génération de
bornes de recharge toujours pour les
véhicules électriques et puis robert
marchand ce centenaire capable de
parcourir plus de 20 km en 1h sur une
piste il détient depuis hier le nouveau
record du monde record battu à saint
quentin en yvelines au vélodrome
nationale bonsoir dominique mot car on
sait donc entrepreneurs inventeur on va
revenir tout à l'heure et sur
quelques-unes de vos créations
innovation puisque et il y en a eu
beaucoup ces dernières années et nous en
avions parlé sur cette antenne puisque
votre histoire est un peu lié à celle de
saint quentin en yvelines
on va tout d'abord parlé de votre
nouveau cheval de bataille c'est une
borne de recharge pour véhicules
électriques
cette borne est juste à côté de vous on
va la voir dans un instant c'est la
société est new motion qui la développe
qu'il apporte
pouvez nous en dire un peu plus déjà sur
cette société ni motion bas merci en
tout cas de m'accueillir sur tv fil 78
et bonne année à tous ceux en tout cas
qui nous écoutent new motion
effectivement est une société qui est né
à amsterdam en 2009 et cette société a
été créée par un créateur un peu un
steve jobs ce monsieur qui avait eu une
idée assez brillante il ya dessinée sur
une feuille blanche aaron blanc et puis
il a fait un renoir il a dit celle ci ça
sera une borne et puis cette borne ne
suffira pas il faut que je crée pas un
apple store à dire je vais créer sur le
cloud
en fin de compte un un support
informatique va permettre d'apporter des
solutions de gestion des recharge pour
les voitures électriques de demain sur
une borne véritablement novatrice c'est
une solution qui s'adresse aussi bien
aux particuliers qu'aux professionnels
alors le secteur c'est ce qui est assez
extraordinaire c'est que le
développement s'est fait d'une façon
exponentielle je vous donnerai tout à
l'heure des chiffres qui qui étonne
parce qu'on est leader aujourd'hui en
europe une motion et l'idée a été au
niveau de la france et donc à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de créer dans
le groupe egis une société filiale qui
est piloté aujourd'hui par jean baptiste
ce berger qui nous vient de sociétés
venant de chez nissan
alain costa qui est un monsieur qui a
toujours oeuvré dans tout ce qui était
énergie électrique distribution de
l'énergie électrique est ce qui fait que
déjà le noyau dur existe et que cette
filiale prend un élan dès le début de
cette année assez incroyable et cette
borne à une particularité c'est
qu'effectivement quand on la regarde sur
le plan du design elle a d'ailleurs
gagné un des grands prix du design
européen
elle est très sobre elle n'a pas changé
ses airs depuis 2009 c'est toujours la
même c'est un peu comme l'est le
téléphone l'iphone que l'on connaît très
bien et voilà c'est exactement la même
chose et sa particularité c'est que l on
connait tous déborde aujourd'hui on a
tous vu assez courant est courant et
puis on écoute un peu tout ce qui est en
train de se passer effectivement il ya
il n'y a pas qu'un effet de mode c'est
que je pense que je fais partie comme
beaucoup d'autres de ceux qui ont essayé
d'évangéliser l'électromobilité
depuis des années et que la enfin après
le mondial de l'automobile 2016 il y
avait vraiment une révélation un déclic
c'est que je pense que tout le monde a
compris ce qu'est un jeune russe la
rentrée d'un gagneur c'est est rentré
dans les moeurs alors qu'est ce qui
change avec cette borne en quoi est-elle
si novatrice vous avec votre portable en
main je vais faire un petit tour très
rapide
quand vous avez un réservoir de 60
litres de d'énergies fossiles dans vos
voitures
il faut comparer par rapport à un bloc
de batteries aujourd'hui qui se balade
entre 40 à 50 kilowattheures partir de
là si je dépense si je fais 100 km je
dépensais environ 6 litres aux cent si
j'ai d'énergie fossile là je vais
dépenser plus tôt aux alentours de 15
kilowatts par heure pour avancer ce qui
fait qu effectivement je vide mes
batteries d'un côté j'ai de l'essence
d'énergies fossiles on va dire à prix
moyen qui est à 1,35 à peu près 2 euros
le litre
de l'autre côté je vais tourner à 0,20
centimes du litre
déjà on réalise de belles et koné voilà
ce qui fait que pour 100 kilomètres d'un
côté avec l'électrique j'en aurais pour
100 kilomètres pour 2 euros
de l'autre côté avec de l'énergie
fossile j'en aurais pour 9 euros
anti-chasse ça montre bien que là il
fallait trouver des solutions après
parce que comme ces voitures ont des
autos money jusqu'à 300 400 500 km il
faut trouver la prise alors là il ya
trois types de prises pour faire très
simple pour que tout le monde le
comprenne bien
si vous avez la petite reprise qui est
celle que l'on met dans son box
un peu quand on a sa maison et qu'on
rajoute dans son garage un congélateur
on met une prise spéciale bat la ceni
c'est pareil on baissa petite reprise
qui elle va des lip et va délibérer
débité environ 2 kilowatts par heure
alors pour un réservoir qui fait 40 faut
une vingtaine d'heures donc
effectivement c'est très long ça coûte
une centaine d'euros
et puis effectivement vous avez votre
voiture dans le garage de l'autre côté
vous avez tous entendu comme moi parler
de tesla et cela ces voitures qui ont
d'une forte autonomie et donc ils ont
mis des chargeurs des super charger qui
coûte plus de 50000 euros et qui eux
vont 10 bits et 50 kilowatts cirque en à
peine une demi heure en voiture se
recharge et donc ça va être plus fait
assurée pour les autoroutes dont les
gens qui sont en tout cas précis et puis
au milieu c'est la gamme new motion on
est dans du 22 kilowatts mains de
kilowatts c'est à dire qu'on va mettre
une heure à une heure et demie pour
charger une voiture et là effectivement
cette tranche juste c'est là où cet
astucieux séquelles comme il porte sa
sur internet
l'idée c'est de dire je vais partager
cette idée alors comment je partage ce
qu'est ce que je fais pendant huit
heures et demie par comme par hasard
quand je
une heure et demie c'est le temps
d'aller faire ses courses donc pendant
que mes courses j'ai la possibilité
d'avoir ma voiture qui va être en charge
donc là on s'adresse aux professionnels
avec un équipement sur un parking par
exemple pour installer ces bornes
exactement une heure et demie on aura à
charge et recharger sa voiture et donc
ça peut être les centres commerciaux ça
peut être les restaurants les courtes
pailles tous ses restaurants en tout cas
un peu rapide ou pendant une heure et
demie pour le particulier on n'est plus
dans la copropriété
et puisque la com on a des emplacements
comment mettre une borne à l'intérieur
des parkings souterrains
là elle répond à cette exigence c'est
effectivement il va y avoir un vrai
enjeu parce que dans les prochaines
années il y aura une obligation un petit
peu pour pour les constructeurs
immobiliers a installé ses bornes
électriques mais pour les constructions
plus anciennes pour les logements les
immeubles
il n'y a pas de solution encore voilà ça
vous vous adressez à eux avec ça
exactement avec avec des solutions au
plus qui sont accompagnés aujourd'hui
grâce à des mesures gouvernementales qui
permet effectivement d'accompagner avec
des groupes comme la veme qui accompagne
avec des missions de subventions qui
vont jusque de l'ordre de 40%
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya vraiment un
accompagnement c'est à dire que par
rapport au prix de la borne 40% et déjà
auto financés par ces subventions
après effectivement dans ces
copropriétés de m une borne par box sa
part être compliqué et là l'idée c'est
de partager aussi c'est à dire que le
système étant intelligent parce que
cette petite borne aujourd'hui elle est
équipée d'une carte sim et cette carte
sim va permettre effectivement de
pouvoir téléphone dont l'adresse est
quand même un devoir pour expliquer
comment ça fonctionne mais donc avec le
téléphone portable on sait si la borne
est disponible pas disponibles et comme
ça on peut réserver sa place en tout cas
exactement comme ça que ça va
fonctionner il a dans ces cas là pour
l'instant vous voyez quel et bouge pas
et est dit absolument rien et là on
vient de réveiller effectivement un
petit voyant qui nous dit que la bordée
libre je me suis identifiée parce que
j'ai été sur le site internet est donc
là j'ai pu m'identifier avec ma carte as
là maintenant je vais passer en termes
de recharge
c'est à dire que là je ne peut plus
retirer maintenant de la carte
c'est à dire que ma prise physiquement
s'il ya quelqu'un qui passe à côté de
moi c'est pas possible j'ai reçu
l'information sur mon portable
il me dit la cession de recharge a
débuté ses nerfs je suis directement
connectée et là je suis passé
effectivement par le club
quand je vais revenir effectivement je
suis au restaurant je vais encore je
suis au fromage je me dis bah tiens les
jeux me fait un petit plaisir c'est le
début de l'année je prends un dessert et
donc ça va me permettre de gagner 15
minutes parce que je sais sur mon
portable que je peux encore en 15
minutes charger suffisamment pour être
en pleine charge
hélas en sortant je reviens je me bats
je me libère et à partir de là j'ai une
libération qui me permet effectivement
de pouvoir retirer ma prise et de
pouvoir repartir
et donc là ce sera rechargée si on veut
installer ce genre de dispositif ça
coûte combien
alors le dispositif aujourd'hui la borne
part elle est elle-même alors c'est ça
qui est assez extraordinaire c'est que
tout ce qu'on a vu jusqu'à présent dans
les bornes vous avez des bornes qui sont
faites en taule en tôle pliée
donc ya pas vraiment un process
industriel la ronde et dans l'injection
plastique donc ça rejoint les métiers
vous savez comme je vous ai parlé
jusqu'à présent la section place qui la
mécatronique la domotique on est dans
dans les objets communicants et là
effectivement pour 850 euros
vous avez une borne qui fait appliquer à
peu près à la moitié moins cher que
toutes les bandes qui existaient pour
l'instant en taule alors ce qui est
intéressant
et là je fais ça sous contrôle à les
éradiquer cette bonne là il y en a
trente mille aujourd'hui trente mille
donc environ 3000 qui sont partagés on a
dix sept mille connexions par jour
17000 que ça fonctionne déjà plutôt pas
mal on en pose vingt bornes par jour en
europe et les chiffres montrent pour la
protection de notre environnement et
c'est je crois que tout le monde veut
savoir aujourd'hui c'est qu'on économise
15 millions de litres par an 15 millions
de litres par an on économise trente six
mille tonnes de co2 derrière rien
qu'avec lyon motion aujourd'hui
simplement avec cette action on a déjà
une action positive pour le domaine de
l'environnement et c'est ça qui est
intéressant et important pour nous au
motion s'était de d'aider et
d'accompagner partout aujourd'hui en
europe
cette mission qui est de développer
l'électromobilité nous motion est un
site internet l'adresse s'est affichée
on a pris beaucoup de temps pour
expliquer donc on va avoir beaucoup
moins pour revenir sur votre parcours et
ça va le faire malheureusement le plus
important encore 30 secondes pour
revenir dessus parce que je les ai
évoqué tout à l'heure en titre vous
avait développé plusieurs procédés qui
permettent de transformer une voiture à
énergie fossile en voiture et énergie et
électrique il ya eu ces voitures qu'on
pouvait piloter avec son smartphone le
kit d'autopartage pour les véhicules
électriques
juste pour revenir sur votre volonté de
vous investir dans ce domaine de
l'automobile et d'électromobilité quel a
été l'élément déclencheur est
aujourd'hui qu'elle quel bilan vous
faites alors je vais part précisé vous
avez 60 ans vous avez passé la moitié de
votre vie à entreprendre et innover
autour de ce domaine vous vivez succès
c'est d'abord une passion je pense que
tout à l'heure vous avez montré
quelqu'un qui a plus de 80 à plus de 100
ans 150 150 encore dans un effectif mans
à faire des records je sais pas si j'en
ai la chance un candide hervé en tout
cas dans tous les cas de figure c'est
une vraie passion et c'est vrai que j'ai
compris assez tôt qu'il fallait
effectivement protéger notre
environnement et qu' il ya une jolie
petite phrase d'ailleurs ça aussi c'est
newton qui le fait c'est qu'est-ce que
pétrole le pétrole papa voilà un et la
réponse c'est quelque chose du passé
larose d'oublier et je pense que c'est
ça qui est qui est important c'est quand
on est dans une grande transition on a
des enfants et il faut partager
aujourd'hui d'autres notre énergie en
tout cas de la façon différente et
d'ailleurs j'en profite sur cette
tablette de chocolat
je veux leur donner les fêtes de
l'énergie positive et de l'énergie
effectivement tout ce qu'il faut pour
effectivement continuer une année 2010
est en pleine santé merci beaucoup
d'être venu nous présenter ce votre
votre nouveau bébé grecque est donc
cette borne nous motion autour de
l'énergie électrique et puis on me
disait effectivement des gens qui aiment
le défi
il en est un qui est un petit peu
l'emblème de toutes ces personnes c'est
robert marchand 105 ans il a battu le
record du monde sur piste
une heure plus de 20 kilomètres
parcourus et on les écoute c'est au
micro deux mais quel est le me d'euros
avec patrick jacques de dixmude merci et
bonne année à tous merci
alors je suis un pro père marchand qui
vient tout juste de réaliser un nouveau
record et je suis également avec michel
logis le présenter au comité la
grammaire 150 ennuis alors robert tout
simplement quelle est votre première
réaction
et ben barek championne c'est formidable
de voir tout de voir tout tout tout tout
seul on que moi j'aurais cru guéret une
centaine de personnes ne pouvant en
dégoûter même pas croyable en ce moment
rien tous les français savent qu'il ya
un type kia qui est bien le meilleur
de fait à un record du monde voilà vous
êtes senti soutenu
bah oui je ressentais à chaque fois
allez allez à là ça fait du bien à l'âme
et y avait mis bas du dos mitry mory à
mais y avait de tout les gens liés à
deux cordes de l'ardèche de choc parce
que vous connaissez l'adage
ils sont sympathiques et quel est votre
secret j'ai pas de secret c'est pas tout
ça mais je ne vais pas jeter ou via sa
d'art et et que j'ai pas de ça car je je
je mange de tout je fais de tout mais je
n'abuse gioia voilà c'est ça le secret
je montrais parce que voilà d'abord
monsieur
michel auger ça encore incroyable
écoutez c'est fantastique en plus robert
marchand il porte bonheur ce vélodrome
en avant du curé en 2014 il a déjà battu
son premier record
le voilà encore donc moi je souhaite
qu'ils battent beaucoup de records ici à
saint quentin et grâce à lui on parle
d'autres agglomérations de ce vélodrome
dont bravo robert merci à la bataille
voilà j'ai là encore le record du monde
de l'heure de l'année avec 44 26 juin
1952 je recherche et recordman du monde
des 100 km d'espoir avec 427 n'est ce
pas
et maintenant je classerais avec le
nouveau avec 22 km et quelque chose
voilà voilà et vous allez continuer ils
demandent si tu vas continuer
bon je ne sais pas il faut quand même en
russie a plu à tout le monde ça ça
m'étonnerait
c'est ce que j'ai fait là tout le monde
peut le faire sur tout le monde parfait
de beaucoup de toiles comme le faire
mais le bloc plus de difficulté c'est de
taper s'entend à ces difficultés la
barre centre parce que on vous dit jalal
kahn a beaucoup en france j'en avais été
habile vous savez faites le calcul ça
fait pas beaucoup c'est la population
vivent les habitants de saint quentin en
yvelines
merci beaucoup robert marchand il ya
bientôt pour de nouveaux records merci
de nous avoir suivis pour cette dernière
édition de la semaine du 7 8 les invités
on se retrouve lundi 18h45 pour la
première diffusion tous les replays sur
notre site internet demain vendredi ce
sera l'hebdo avec nicolas kirillovitch
[Musique]